si elle est un petit peu plus grosse que
la moyenne de ce crime elle est de
retour sur les étals des marchés la
sucrine du berry cette courge de couleur
ocre légèrement sucré a séduit ce
producteur qui en a récupéré les
semences paysannes pour la cultiver
il ya de chez moi que les gens peuvent
en trouver parce que personne ne fait ça
donc voila moi je moi j'ai plaisir à
refaire si les variétés anciennes c'est
important pour moi parce que je les fais
toujours fait pour moi donc je veux
faire connaître aux gens de toutes ces
choses que convaincre on voit nulle part
faire revivre les légumes anciens c'est
aussi l'objectif 10 à groupe dans ses
jardins d'insertion l'association joue
le rôle de mainteneur elle cultive
notamment le haricot baron jonnier ou
encore le chou navet blanc d'aubigny sur
nère disparu depuis les années 70 c'est
la racine en fête du légume qui est de
couleur blanche sur sa partie inférieure
avec un collet vert sur sa partie
supérieure
quand on va sélectionner on va
privilégier en fait de garder cette
semence cela qui se rapprochera du faqih
se rapprochera qui nous redonnera le
chou navet a collé vers dominique pour
qu'une variété soit commercialisée elle
doit figurer au catalogue officiel des
variétés légumière la sucrine du berry
et le haricot barre en jaune y ayant
fait leur retour et peuvent être
transformés mais ce n'est pas encore le
cas pour le chou navet blandeau bini